does this process look like in terms of
if you know we are talking about working
with each other on a retained basis yeah
absolutely it does look different I
think you kind of
kind of you want to work the role
retained anyway we'll get to the end of
the call and I'll know that I can what I
want to pitch retain for this particular
role and then I would talk to the client
around it you know probably will likely
be a client that I've worked with for a
period of time as well to be honest so
it is new you know that they're not a
new client to me but it's a new way of
working with them so it's all about kind
of framing it I guess to say you know
this is how we've been working more
recently and it's having just a
magnificent result for our clients and
we've filled every single role in doing
so